les chaînes je parle les chérit le
retour de jean bourassa c'est le retour
de la star ya derrière pipe via la belle
balle ou yahoo will i am qui nouveau
genre actuel qui bosse avec l'odieuse du
coup oui laquelle
[Musique]
rhum coca et moshen nanterre mais
kenneth r il y aura même eu dans sa
série no3 york pour tourner sa sincérité
sa styliste et du contenu
5 car ça a été volé sa vie plus ni moins
[Musique]
c'est grillé mon pote tu es crié on va
bientôt carrière de leurs maux
[Musique]
ce qui est génial dans les événements
frais légumes d'alsace cqeer toujours
des supers chose à manger
d'ailleurs je viens de capter quelques
dit il me semble assez family la lutte
tu ne prends pas de rides
bb c'est ta première c'est important
c'est comme la première fois quand on
fait l'amour c'est pas la table donc tu
vas toute sa vie voilà un bébé non t'es
pas cet été la star durant ta dernière
dans le vrac les gones ont alors qu'ils
estiment que ce qui se passe
[Musique]
etc
voilà je voudrais
[Musique]